[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
forgive my compromised sense of humor
but I did want to answer our host
question about who Jude Law is he's one
of our finest actors and what but Jude
and all other talented actors know is
that for every greatly talented actor
there are five actresses who are nothing
short of magic and the Academy's the
Academy's favorite five this year or
Annette Bening in being Julia Catalina
Sandino Moreno in Moorea full of grace
and Mel de Staunton in Vera Drake
Hilary Swank in Million Dollar Baby Kate
Winslet in Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to Hillary Swank
this is the second Academy Award for
Hilary Swank who took home her first
Oscar for her leading role in boys don't
cry she's also the first female in
Academy history to be nominated for
playing a boxer
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know what I did in this life
does it deserve all this I am I'm just a
girl from a trailer park who had a dream
I never thought this would ever happen
let alone be nominated and a working
actor for that matter and now this I
think the Academy I am eternally
grateful for this great honor I would
also like to annul it acknowledge my
fellow nominees
Annette Imelda Kate and Catalina your
work inspires me beyond words I am going
to start by thanking my husband because
I'd like to think I learn from past
mistakes Chad you're my everything thank
you for your support it means the world
I would never be standing here if it
weren't for the each and every one of
the brilliant people had surrounding me
supporting me and believing in me
Tom Rosenberg Gary Lucchese thank you
for sending me this most marvellous
script you will never know how grateful
I am Paul Haggis for writing this
beautiful script our other producers
extraordinaire already Clint rabe Lorenz
Phyllis Huffman our casting director my
trainers grant Robertson Hector oka you
pushed me further than I ever thought I
could push myself up to that last pound
actually to that last ounce I thank you
my sparring partners are who were so
patient and everyone at Gleason's let's
see
well the ever amazing Morgan Freeman
Tom Stern our cinematographer you are
brilliant
Joel Cox our editor you're amazing you
know I'm going to thank my mom for
believing in me from the beginning my
dad for his support my agent's Josh
Lieberman Tony lip Kelly tiffin John
Campisi
Jason Weinberg my manager uh you can't
do that because I haven't gotten to
Clint yet I saved him for the end Karl
lost in Jeff Bernstein my my lawyers and
then Clint Clint Eastwood thank you for
allowing me to go on this journey with
you thank you for believing in me
you're my macushla thank you alan horne
and warner brothers as well thank you
and you know what wait
[Applause]